[Musique]
le comté du shérif adjoint james kennedy
compte 200 km de frontière avec le
mexique à cause de cette proximité il
écope aussi des dommages collatéraux
générés par le trafic de clandestins
mais surtout par le trafic de drogue
[Musique]
avec
une bonne partie de la solution à ce
problème selon lui c'est ce fameux mur
haut de 10 mètres et plus efficace
dit-il que la mince clôture de métal qui
existait avant cette frontière s'étend
sur plus de 3000 km jusqu'ici environ
550 kilomètres de murs ont été bâties
mais attention il s'agit surtout de mur
qui a remplacé dès clôture existante
quand on parle de murs vraiment nouveau
seulement quelques kilomètres aurait été
construit john ladd et éleveurs de
bétail sont wrench jouxte la frontière
mexicaine sur une distance de 15 km pour
ce républicain convaincu lui poser une
question sur l'utilité du mur appelle
une réponse évidente le mur selon lui va
permettre de diminuer le nombre de
clandestins assoiffés ou affamés qui
meurent sur sa propriété
le mur si efficace soit-il pour juguler
le trafic humain et celui des drogues
comporte quelques trous ça et là comme
ici où on peut traverser sans problème
de l'autre côté un mur incomplet c'est
un autre problème à gérer pour le compte
et murs ou pas les trafiquants
s'adaptent un ingénieur qui estime que
tous ceux qui passent la frontière
doivent être expulsées immédiatement a
mis au point un système de surveillance
de la frontière par drones
vidéo le mur de trump dont il est un
fervent partisan c'est bien dit il mais
sans système de détection ni de
technologies de surveillance
ce n'est pas suffisant c'est juste de la
poudre aux yeux
pendant ce temps john laddh se croisent
les doigts pour que donald trump soit
réélu sinon selon lui ce sera la
catastrophe pour le mur au paintball
chaussures raison quatre ans après la
promesse du président trump le mur et le
contrôle de l'immigration sont au moins
à l'avant plan et cela on inquiète
certains importants et sexuelle mais
aussi controversé est politisé soit-il
le mur de la frontière se construit
maintenant à une cadence accélérée
d'environ 15 km par semaine